[Musique]
merci mon jean luc et cette année
également comme je l'aï dit tout à
l'heure il ya un garçon qui nous a
rejoint ce garçon c'est maxime qui dit
maxime gainey qui est célibataire
vous avez énormément de succès maxime
c'est vrai non mais franchement vous le
sentez ça ou pas avec les filles ça se
passe bien mais ça se passe très bien
entre est bien léger les messages
vraiment très bienveillant de plein de
personnes qui veulent que j'aï boire un
verre avec elle
ah oui là bas mais même j'en ai un peu
trop donc moi qui n'a jamais été le le
coeur de l'attention va sorti avec une
fille depuis six mois ouais c'est sûr le
louvre regardez
maxime gainey le séducteur et juste
après j'ai une très belle surprise pour
vous regarde je m'entends très bien avec
mes anciennes copines c'est celle de
milan 3 1 3 ça fait quand même temps
vous êtes célibataire aux faits a fait
on va dire deux ans tu préfères les
femmes plus mûres non pas puisque ça ou
vous bonsoir vous êtes magnifique
s'appelait jean michel mr jeu d'accord
peu qu'elle lui c'est quoi ça paie
heineken va se defendre débattre mais je
te le dis était venu ici pour faire du
média oui je t'ai pas vu ici pour
qu'elle a tout va beaucoup nous
regardons si t'appelles jeu si c'est ça
fait longtemps que l'on table comme ça
j'ai toujours depuis ma naissance du
plaisir en tout cas merci beaucoup c'est
toi beaucoup de dunes coup de coeur du
jour c'est tatiana silva la nouvelle
présentatrice de tf1
elle est arrivée après 52 - leproux jc
je ne rejette pas tout d'abord sonné la
gated aussi entre maxime gagné tatiana
silva
je les trouvais vraiment très très bien
maxime gainey est ce que oui ou non vous
êtes sur le dos non c'est non
[Musique]
c
maxime taton année on a mis une petite
annonce pour vous ouais essentielle
d'une parodie au départ j'ai fait la
parodie des des princes de l'amour et on
a émis une adresse mail véritable atlas
mail et je crois que vous avez eu
beaucoup de demande en croissance pour
son mail 300 messages soit béni d'un
maxi je vous demander de partir quoi ce
plateau vous avez partir de ce plateau
parce que votre vie va changer ce soit
maxime allez-y on va vous viendront
chercher bas venait le chercher
maxime des ninjas d'aller dans un
endroit dans lequel votre vie va changer
maxime gagnon va le retrouver dans un an
lors il va prendre une moto et que vous
allez voir on va le retrouver et je
regrette boulât du bois de boulogne
[Rires]
votre colis va changer et oui vous
verrez on va le retrouver dans quelques
minutes maxime galy rester bien avec
nous je pense que il va être très très
très content vous allez voir merci très
bonne balle de jean michel maire je
pense que ça va pas durer longtemps
merci jean michel vous faites vraiment
un prime et et regarder maxime gainey il
est arrivé à l'endroit où ils devaient
être maxime est ce que tu m'entends mon
maxi est ce que tu m'as
mais la roma xi alors là une magnifique
villa pour maxim guérin avec toutes les
jeunes filles qui nous écrit non voilà
je sais pas c'est tout des jeunes filles
qui nous écrit dans ce cas il ya l'air
d'avoir une très bonne ambiance
regardez maxime gaignard yves besselat
away faudrait plus de son les chéris
ouais
parce que vous êtes content maxime
allais autres tenez maxime est ce que
vous voudrez est-ce que vous pouvez
aller donner le bouquet de fleurs à la
jeune fille qui est au bout du pont là
bas maxime reculer d'abord avant de
l'avoir et toi et voulu passer un petit
poème la mer assez chaud pour cela il
vous lui fassiez un petit poème forêts
du rhône alors quelques de la deuxième
demie merci alors c'est l'instant poèmes
aujourd'hui je suis content de
t'entendre je suis content de te voir tu
es aussi belle que la rosée du matin
toutes les femmes de ma vie aujourd'hui
rio dit tuez les chéris de mes envies et
grâce à toi je crois qu'aujourd'hui
c'est le grand soir mais cette jeune
fille elle est très mignonne franchement
très mignonne demander un maillot deux
pièces c'est juste parfait demander du
monde dames et vous chers de moselle
j'adore jaquette lettre est ce que à
lettres de l'amour et autres merci vous
en dis des conneries
oui oui ça m'arrive ouais maxime est ce
que vous voulez aller la rejoindre ou
est-ce que vous préférez rester de
l'autre côté du pont vous savez là je
pense qu'on est à une dizaine de mètres
j'ai des roses d'une grande qualité la
sent bon ça sent la rose et je vais les
viols vous la portez avec coeur allez
amour fraternel pour l'instant j'avais
demandé à la jeune fille est ce que vous
voulez qu'ils viennent nous rejoindre
jade elle n'attend que ça et bien
allez-y aller entre l'amour coupable
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
à
max goeldi qu'on peut applaudir
regardez comme il est heureux d'aller
pas me les noyers n'allais pas me noyer
sa maxime
c est ce que vous voulez voir le reflet
quand même on n'a pas le respect pour ce
contentieux
regardez on va voir attendait c'est
magnifique à lise août
c'est mal bon bah écoutez a beau la vie
c'est pas c'est pas aujourd'hui qui va
pêcher merci merci à l'essai bamba
boléro maxime bono match par colin firth
à la maxime
il est mignon il est beau il est beau
gars ce jeu-là d'or ce mec